the nail-biting race to the white house
continues now into a third day
today and this evening and it's still
too close to call a winner for president
of the united states
we thank you for joining us at six i'm
brian loftis and i'm denise valdez so
let's start by taking a look at the
overall
electoral map and where joe biden and
president trump stand
across the country right now the race
closer still here in nevada as we
continue to count ballots
nevada has been really just thrust into
the national spotlight
as a key battleground state in the
election and today we got an
update on the counting that is going on
here in clark county to take a look at
the latest numbers a very slim margin
of lead by joe biden over president
trump
8 news now reporter joe moeller is live
now to explain
joe well there's a demonstration
where we're at right now we're right
outside the election center throughout
the day when we're supposed to get that
update regarding the election results
there was demonstrators earlier today
and they've been lingering throughout
the day and behind us this group is
really growing as a protest is about to
start but
around the nation all eyes have been on
nevada people wanting to get some sort
of update here
but the race still too close to paul
here at the election center 51 000 votes
were set to be counted today
those results won't come in until
tomorrow morning at yet another news
conference
according to the secretary of state 190
000 remain to be counted in nevada and
90 percent of those are in clark county
there is only a 12 000 vote different so
it is a tight race
mail ballots continue to come in as well
today the registrar of voters for clark
county said he doesn't expect to get the
bulk of mail ballots until this weekend
our goal here in clark county is not to
count fast
we want to make sure that we're being
accurate the results in the state of
nevada obviously are going to be very
important to the entire country and that
is our number one goal
a handful of voters who need to have
their id verified have been contacted
and have to do so by tomorrow at 5 pm
mail ballots will continue to be counted
as well through november 12th
they simply had to be postmarked by the
third to count it is possible we won't
know if the state will go blue
or red for a few days now back out here
live this demonstration is continuing
this evening
a lot of trump supporters protesting the
accounting process this is just getting
underway here
this big plan protest but again the next
update we expect as far as election
results go is tomorrow at 10 a.m
reporting live in north las vegas